You're so weird, Otis.
I'm not… I'm not normal.
Of course you're normal.
You and your mum are freaks.
I was just starting to feel
like a normal teenager
and now you go and make me
feel like a freak again!
You're doing it!
-Again!
-You used to care a lot.
Things are easier
when you don't care.
Maeve Wiley
just likes playing
with people's feelings
and she doesn't really care
about anyone.
-What happened?
-You are so self-centred.
You don't care about anyone
but yourself!
I rang your mum
to pick me up
because this is
where I felt safe.
I think I made a mistake.
It's wrong, Otis.
Well, I don't think it is.
Are you ok?
He's being so weird.
Jonathan!
How could you?
No, I don't want
to talk about it.
I'll mess you up.
I'm scared.
How could you possibly
help me?
You did this.
What have you done?